>> We are pleased to announce Android 2.2.
There are four areas we'd like to highlight
in this video. We're working to continue improving
overall speed and performance on Android.
In Android 2.2, the newly introduced Dalvik
JIT Compiler delivers a two to five X performance
boost to CPU-bound code compared to Android
2.1. In this demo version of the game Replica
Island, the screen turns red when the CPU
is unable to keep the game simulation thread
above 30 frames per second. Here, the Android
2.2 device with JIT maintains a game simulation
frame rate above 35, while the 2.1 device
quickly goes below 30. Developers can use
Android Cloud to Device Messaging to easily
enable alerts, send to phone, and two-way
sync functionality for their Apps. With this
API, an App server can send authenticated
messages to the Google server, which would
push the message to the App on a user's device.
In this example, a developer has used Android
Cloud to Device Messaging to enable a URL
send to phone extension from the desktop browser
that automatically opens the push page with
the appropriate App here at Google Maps. The
App Backup API enables any App to have its
data backed up and then restored when installed
on a new device. The feature is controlled
by users via the automatic restore setting
on their device. With Android 2.2, developers
can specify whether they want their App installed
on a device's SD card. For Apps residing on
the SD card, users can move the App from the
SD card to internal storage and back from
the manage application settings. Android 2.2
introduces the ability to use ones phone as
a portable hotspot. Users can activate portable
hotspot on their phone then connect their
computer to the portable hotspot to get internet
access. We're continuing to make the browser
better and faster. Android 2.2 introduces
the V8 JavaScript engine which provides a
two to three X improvement in JavaScript rendering
times compared to Android 2.1. You can see
the difference in the side-by-side visualizations
of the respective SunSpider JavaScript benchmarking
test results.
We're introducing several new features to
Android market. Users can choose to let an
App auto-update as long as permissions remain
unchanged. Users can also update all Apps
with unchanged permissions with a single click.
Application Error Reports will provide to
developers App crash and freeze reports submitted
by users. These reports will be available
to developers through their Android Market
publisher account. To learn more about Android
2.2, please go to our website, developer.android.com.